[Music]
do
[Music]
it's gonna end sometime
the overpowering sound of nico's hand
pan and film shoebox guitar that i play
and my drop d tuning with my old strings
my old strings my words strings
boys i got the o that's the name of your
first album
mild strings
funny noises on this thing let me tell
you a tale about the old
strings
niko's got a funny noise for us everyone
stop what you're doing
and listen to this hear a funny noise
oh that is hilarious oh my god i haven't
laughed like this in years
guys what are we what are we doing what
are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
the heck are you doing we're launching
we're launching a website that's what
we're doing
we already launched a website we're
launching website dot dot dot
again i mean we're
constantly launching the website that's
the thing about it but yeah
scott came on today for a special
because uh by the time this podcast
comes out
on thursday uh wednesday is
our phase two drop
tomorrow yeah also
scott we brought you here so you can
give us all your hot takes on uh
british politics yeah to be prepared
we're actually we're gonna solve we're
gonna solve brexit
in this podcast yeah tell us everything
like we had quite not this christmas
because this christmas was a coat
it was a covered christmas but the
christmas before it got
quite heated uh around my cousin's house
to the point where
i almost got thrown out of christmas
because it was basically me
calling everybody else idiots um it
usually works out well
yeah i like how they do that in the
middle of parliament
i like how they stand up and insult each
other oh yeah
in the middle of parliament when you
watch it
you just go what a bunch of children but
that's just how it's always been
we've been doing this same thing for 2
000 years
i can't believe they almost threw you
out it's that's sad they almost threw
you out just because you think it's
worth
having you know the uk being a separate
country it's
it's crazy right
how about that let's not let's leave
british politics
to the british politicians sorry not to
put words in your mouth
yeah let's talk about quarter digital
yeah i know
that was just a bit sorry let's not
start off this podcast on like all the
wrong feet
[Laughter]
anyway hey scott do you want to come on
the podcast and get bombarded with
political questions that have nothing to
do with what
you don't mean new things to talk about
we got this website we also have like
this collab with linus tech tips that
we've been doing yes
and like those are both super exciting i
don't even know where to start but
honest honestly hold on
put the website talk on pause vintage
mac os
oof oh yeah man that's we're all about
here right now you know some men like
cars someone men like their trucks
some men also like mac os seven
like get one of those babies perrin yeah
so this man likes early ios
so we had this idea i eat mac os for
breakfast man use
photoshop 1.0 and to try using that to
do things like to do visual effects or
whatever and
because you know what would it be what
is the first photoshop like who knows
right so
uh we were kind of poking around trying
to figure out how we could do this idea
and
i reached out to linus at linus tech
tips back in like august
and yeah he's like that's a cool idea so
anyways
uh life happened time passed and then he
sent me an email like
two or three months ago saying like hey
so we did that
i'm like did what it's like we uh got
photoshop 1.0 running on an og macintosh
and he's like oh really he's like yes
and uh when you're ready we'll send it
to you and it's like oh really
so so that's super cool and uh we got
the machine
last week and it's pretty crazy so the
macintosh is from 1993
it's older than a lot of people here at
corridor yeah multiple there are
multiple people
who were born after that computer was
made yeah
and uh they they not only had photoshop
1.0 installed on it they also installed
some games on it now
it's worth pointing out here that both
myself and sam basically got
our start on computers like this one um
i was on a macintosh performa as my
first computer i'm sure sam was on
something similar
i don't remember the specific ones
because it was power's pc before i could
like
comprehend what the actual like computer
models were
you know yeah but it's basically this
machine that we got and so immediately
sam and i were
transported back to our youth our
youthful childlike wonder
and you know like hey computers wow
these are really neat who know
i wonder if this will be important in my
lifetime you know what actually
i'm sorry i like i know fatherhood keeps
it's a recurring subject on the podcast
as we're all
fathers but i mean
okay look everyone's you know even
myself i'm concerned about like screen
time for kids
and all this stuff but the moment i
opened that box
with you and we've set that computer up
i was like wait a second
like some of my best childhood memories
were like
effing around on an old back and either
making crazy art with it
or playing these crazy games before
people like
before there was like a formula to
writing games you know and
i don't know it was like something kind
of beautiful and i instantly
instantly thought like oh man i i gotta
get an old mac
so my kid can have that same experience
i'm sure he's gonna hate it but
um but i don't know there's there's
something special there and it really
changes that whole perspective of
all right you know screen time life
experiences you know like are you
messing with your kid too much you know
blah blah blah um but anyway sorry
tangent
well i think the big thing is like the
moment you fire up the computer you're
like
oh no micro transactions
no dlc no constant updates
no patches everything is just shipped as
is
and it's a one-click mouse for
simple people like me and you dude i
can't believe i can't tell you how many
times
i right clicked that mouse just on habit
trying to do stuff i was like i need to
find an info and i like right click i
just hit i'm just
hitting the same button with my middle
finger
yeah it's it's an absolute joy to use
that computer
it's just so simple and straightforward
it kind of reminds me of how much
like there's some good stuff going on in
software these days don't get me wrong
but there's a lot of really crappy
garbage like there's so much of just
like like what
well you know a good example is like you
know
take steam for example right imagine you
want to sit down and play your video
games
well steam has to update cms update
almost every time you open it so it
should be a quick you know 30 seconds to
20 seconds for the program to open
becomes a
one to two minutes pretty much every
time you want to use it and then games
have to update every time and then
little by little they bloat themselves
up from 10 gigs to 20 gigs to 30 gigs to
40 gigs
so never do you have just a thing that
is
you always have something that's
amorphous and shifting and you can't
just rely on a game to be that game
it's going to constantly change it's
going to constantly update and it's kind
of a pain in the ass
you can't just come back to something
it's like a book where you can like open
it up and the words are still on the
same page as where they were earlier
it's like imagine you put a bookmark in
a book and you come back to it a few
months later and like
now your page is like 50 pages back and
you're like wait what that's what
happens because i have toddlers
[Laughter]
yeah i said no i i hear that i hear that
i
updating steam was i've had some of the
most frustrating software experiences
like
just trying to because also they
they have all the password protection
tiers and so
it's like if you're signing in on a new
device then it's
you know there's three layers of removal
and then it's like oh was it that
account or was it was it the other
account that i had and then
each one each time it has to update it's
yeah it's a real
unless you're using it every day and you
know adobe does the same thing and all
the software programs we use now do the
same thing like if you step away from
them for a minute
you have to spend an hour rebooting
everything once you come back to it
yeah you know the only thing that's just
the only thing that's like
that's similar to like this old
macintosh in terms of experience is
honestly like
video uploads once you upload a video
onto youtube
that's it it lives there forever you
don't really get to change it
like yeah so you make sure it's good and
you watch it for bugs and errors and
glitches before it goes live
people don't do that really that often
with software
these days print and patch
sorry scott we're talking about you and
your ilk
you developer types we know your types
but as we say it's a feature not a bug
so it's like i mean one of the one of
the first things that was taught to me
is that it was like
if you ever say that your piece of
software is bug free
you just haven't found it yet yeah there
is no such thing as a bug-free piece of
software
like sure if it's a really really small
program
then fine but with every new feature
and every layer and you know it just
you know it does become in some cases
needed a haystack and other times you'll
go
i should have just seen that like it was
so obvious and i tested everything
except for that one thing
um hey so scott i don't think it's ever
been talked about
on on the last few times you've been on
the cast but
like how did you get into everything
that you do
because when i when i got in touch with
you you are you had already been in the
game for like 10 years of
of doing programming and compression and
all that stuff yeah so i mean
like the the the roots of it all was
sort of um like picked up gaming and
computers
a lot of that sort of the inspiration
came from my grandad who
you know in his 80s was was like using
photoshop
and was editing um you know with
you know digital camera all of the stuff
that he did for like weddings for
friends and family um so i was always
interested in computers
and then was gonna go to either
university as
an engineer or basically take my pilot's
license
and make that commercial license so then
i would do
like um naughty oil rig flying or
something like that um
and then somehow kind of just landed on
computer science
um originally wanted to do games
development but was kind of like
i won't limit myself to by just saying
games only
i was like i'll do the core and then see
where that takes me
yeah um and then got a job straight out
of uni
um sort of had two job offers one was
near my parents one wasn't
so i went with the one that wasn't
not that i don't love my parents but you
know when you're
21 you don't really want to live at home
yeah you have that separation yeah
yeah and then through that company
i did some work with um technicolor's
platform
called mgo where i built built their
desktop app
um and then i started in the world of
sony
so i then spent the next eight nine ten
years
um working for sony pictures building
their direct consumer platforms
and that's pretty much where i learned
everything from you know
back-end systems front-end websites so
can can we officially say that we stole
you from sony
uh yes you can officially
say that sure where'd you find scott
uh we stole them from sony pictures
yeah in culver city so sunny don't be
careful
sunny sunny pictures sunny boy pictures
sunny boy you know that's why they're
called sony right
because they wanted like a god cool
western sounding like sunny boy
and they're like that's that's cool
western sound
it's it's 100 percent true that's 100
true it's shockingly true
they weren't started yeah this is like
afterwards
they want like a good old american boy
name and so like sunny
and like they spelled it with one end so
it's funny
i'm not kidding you that is actually not
called sony
yeah is that like is that like the evic
story yeah
yeah like his parents i don't know if
his parents wanted to name it eric or
not
but yeah we're not at
liberty to develop divulge that story
technically but
yeah um yeah i didn't know wait is that
true
about sony the sunny boy one is 200 true
yes
you can't tell if you're trolling me it
depends on if you believe wikipedia or
not
check it out the it's old news interwebs
says that it came from sonos
which is latin for
sound maybe the fact that their first
their first consumer product was an
electric rice cooker
yeah that's what i'm that's what i'm
thinking like if they're they're they
started off in electronic and consumer
products
not in motion pictures so i i don't know
no go to wikipedia we're we're good
we're going to get to the bottom of this
right now i'm pulling it up sony was
combined by the two words of sonus and
sunny
oh yeah oh yeah a common slang term for
the 1950s
in america to call a young boy sunny
no this this okay this is this is the
official sony.com
okay the company name of sony was
created by combining two words of sonus
and sunny
the word sonus and latin yeah sound etc
the other word sunny
means little sun using combinations sony
is supposed to represent a very small
group of young people who have the
energy and passion
towards unlimited creations and
innovative ideas no but that's
yeah can we start calling can we start
calling people in the
sunny sony yeah
sorry peter's our sony boy
no just call him sunny boy just just
stick with the original
hey snow it's so much funnier to say
sunny
sony boy is it is it is it um
sonny b to dean now or instead of child
beater dean
sony peter dean yeah anytime people pick
the little boys like ness or villager
it'll be like
it'll just be different sunnies
sunniness
and sunny villager sunniness
yeah yeah so
so wow so that's so that's why you got
your experience because
like when you first hit us up two years
ago at this point
uh you you basically said hey i can
build this
and i said yeah i told samantha i was
like yeah this guy emailed me and says
that he can build us a website
yeah and then like a week later you had
these video
you had a bunch of stuff in place uh
that was kind of like proof of concept
yeah and that was pretty cool that that
changed my opinion pretty quickly
yeah well it was one of those i
genuinely
didn't expect to get a response and you
replied like maybe a day or two later
and i was just like
holy crap like what do i do now
no i think that's how most people end up
most people end up
in corridor with that same that same
experience like
we're about to put out a hiring video on
the same day that this podcast comes out
and uh we're gonna get i mean that's how
we've been hiring
and we've found so many great people
that way like we just reach out to the
audience and we say
hey guys uh we need somebody that's
really good at this
anybody know anybody or anybody watching
this video
and um yeah and
that's how we found dean that's how we
found matt
that's how we found peter
um it's like you know it's endless
yeah basically everyone except
ren nick no ren wren technically he
found us through our videos
wren showed
and we were unsure of like who he was
because he was just like i'm a fan and
he like drove down to check out the
building
and we had no idea what was going on
we're like who is this guy like what's
going on and then he just manages to
like be in freddie and brandon's video
yeah that they're about to shoot oh he
almost had a broken fluorescent light
tube dropped on his head
the shot went perfectly and it fell
around his head
what video yeah i saw i saw that video
the splinter cell one where freddy's
shooting out light bulbs with uh
airsoft gun actually shooting out for us
and light bulbs in our hallway with an
airsoft gun
yeah i'm sure steve wasn't pissed about
that at all really replaced them
but there was broken glass and mercury
everywhere
so um scott i
i i'd like to take an opportunity to
just like
expand a little bit on everything we
just did to the site
because i i know that you and i
appreciate it
you perhaps more than anybody wait wait
because wait jake i
just gotta cut you off this will
approach us with way more hype
you gotta be honest
yep we've spent the last eight months
renovating corridor digital.com for you
today
not only are we releasing functional
filmmaking one of the greatest
educational digital media creative
videos and series of all time
we also have four new features on our
green light page what is the green light
page well through your website
subscription dollars
you can put your dollars at work
to see what projects we create
through the green light feature we've
got four new projects and also
last but not least we have peter's smush
brethren
and also what's on the green light page
we got new things on the green light
page that's right yeah we're already
we're still working on the first things
and they're coming great they're coming
along great
well you'll be able to see the first
episode of functional filmmaking right
now yeah and we're knee deep in editing
son of a dungeon and we're
basically on the verge now finally being
ready to do local zero which is crazy
it's taking a lot of work
but that's because no one else is doing
stuff like that that's why it's hard
anyways yeah
when we when you when i just watched the
editing video
or the hiring video and i i don't know
i'm honestly questioning how many people
exist in the universe that are going to
know
how to do that job i know two people and
one of them
one already said no he can't help us
that's like where i'm at but what do we
got for the new ones we got
the cord or digital forums can we at the
corridor forums
so that's that's it you know what you
know what it might not sound like
something you accompany
like trumpets with where like forums and
you're like
but it's pretty sweet actually because
forums offer a completely different
social media experience something that's
not
determined by algorithms and it's not
based on a like a
this this this like kind of temporary
you know flash in the pan style like
you know ordering of like how you you
know
consume information uh burning trash
fires but it's nice because
what it's nice to consolidate it because
it becomes a repository of knowledge
rather than
like this you know doom-scrolling kind
of
freaking i got nothing
yeah just out there hey man what'd you
do last night i was just out there
doomsday i do scroll for three hours and
then fell asleep
that's it i mean i mean all those
algorithms are made to like keep you on
the side as long as possible yeah
exactly um so anyway but it's cool
uh i don't know what else we can do with
the cool art that griffin and ren made
for it because
i feel like i mean it's got some legs
t-shirt that's got that's got t-shirt
written all over it
i know i know it does we should have
just we should create a pat like
scott has on the mocap hoodie or the
mocap crew neck
we should create a pattern with ren just
riding the onewheel through cyberspace
great love it yeah i mean yeah we just
do the 90s internet kid
shirt but it's ren on a one i'm gonna
write that down real quick
so i don't see this is how we need to be
doing merch guys dude it's not on the
fourth stretch
what what about when the point and then
that's the porsche sure that's in there
sure and lehman's tiny hut it's the best
pro shops
lehman's tiny hut is definitely and
there's got to be an american flag on
the freaking
sleeve or or the backwards flag the
assaulting flag yeah
yeah because it's got to be like one of
those like you get this one in the
middle of wyoming at a freaking
cabela's it's a grunt style yeah yeah
there's there's a fish somewhere on it
yeah anyways um
anyway so forums that's great stuff so
we got forums we got corridor live
quarterly podcasts once once corner live
gets greenlit
if it gets greenlit all these podcasts
are going to be live so yeah that's
another
one um peter's new bones peter's name
let's not forget
yeah that's the bonus number five that's
not gonna be live
on wednesday but we have a green light
feature called peter's new bones
it's six it's 206 points only
and only you can only put in one point
and for each point
there's 206 people at the end they each
get one of peter's new bones yeah they
they
they each contributed and now people
might be asking well i thought it was
only a hundred dollars
to get them new bones yeah i thought
only a hundred dollars get new bones
we did our math wrong when we wrote that
you need 206
to get new bones because that's how many
bones
we had to double the we had to double
the price and then we got charged
six dollars of interest
[Laughter]
packaging packages long awaited yeah
what else we got
what else we got in the green light page
well we have
dubstep guns 10 10.
[Laughter]
i'm calling it 10 because it makes more
sense in my head dubstep guns
x ooh dubstep guns x x there it is
artwork for dubstep guns 2 is sick
it is i just i still can't stop looking
at it it's just
it looks so good yeah yeah griffin
nailed it
griffin directed guns too what just
happened yeah
so what what is this nico can you
summarize maybe a little bit of
of what you want to shoot there is there
a plot well assuming it gets greenlit
uh if good listeners here uh decide to
help us out
and green light it the premise is
generally that
the drop squad is all washed up
like i'm i don't know i spend most of my
time on the floor of my motel room
sam just has a nice job at an insurance
company
and mike is no has been nowhere to be
seen for the past eight years
mike has mike mike moved to a tropical
island and he has nine children oh i
mean i think i think
i think you just have to look at you
know dubstep guns was based off of
the world around us when it was made
where a place a beautiful place where
dubstep was popular
you know it's people think it's fiction
but there's a lot of reality in that
story and so you know you look at
10 years later dubstep guns x
it's it's based in 2021 a world where
dubstep is frowned upon shunned people
who listen to it or play it
are are cast out from society yep um
yeah so almost certainly i tried to
start a dubstep club
and i went bankrupt because i refused to
play any other types of edm
[Laughter]
dubstep only club yeah yeah it's a peak
a glimpse into a few characters who have
refused to let go of dubstep
yeah but you know the world needs us
because there is a rivalry which is the
rivalry of metal music and dubstep
uh and who has the coolest breakdown oh
i thought the greatest enemy was going
to be soundcloud rappers
oh it's a whole mix of things actually
soundcloud rappers yeah you're right
uh but mike will be coming back in to
help us make it uh we'll be
brainstorming and writing together
um i don't think we're gonna pull
all-nighters this time trying to crank
out vfx but uh it'll still be sweet
um yeah and i do want to have a a sword
section where the sword choreography is
in tune with music just like the lasers
were
yeah that'd be cool yeah and it's gonna
be this
one's a little bit unique because that
one's not exclusive to the website that
one's gonna be going on youtube
so you know all the website patrons will
be helping us
uh helping everyone in the world by
greenlighting this one because this
one's going out to everybody this is not
a
keep it for ourselves kind of thing yeah
yeah and that's something um like
eventually
if we do son of a dungeon season two
like when we drop that
we will probably release son of a
dungeon season one
on youtube and obviously we we put out
the first
episode of functional filmmaking as a
teaser for people
to see so they know kind of they get a
feel for what the series is
um so you know i think some of that
stuff's good to do to like draw in
a larger audience who might not you know
see it or recognize that it's there yeah
um and then obviously we have crew cuts
season two because
that's a thing daniel's made over 50
episodes of crew cuts did you guys yeah
they're really good he's really good at
it he
yeah i i don't i don't want to
i i don't want to have him hear this and
have him get real big for his britches
not that he's that type of person
he's he's the he's the most like nicest
most humble man um but he is an
incredible filmmaker
he's he's been able to find some of
these like
stories and through lines just through
like
watching people and asking questions and
filming it
it's pretty wild yeah do you think we'll
ever do a dvd box set of the vlogs
[Laughter]
no but we should probably release like a
a highlight series
of the best episodes from season one on
corridor crew at some point like you
know just
because again i think people i think
there's a huge section of that audience
that that would would really appreciate
it i think that's a really
really really good idea because a lot of
the the thing is is that even though
like vlogs can sometimes be um
tied to the time they're released
um a lot of the time when he releases
these vlogs you know sometimes yeah
they're about projects
but they have like a kind of an
encompassing vibe to them
where it doesn't feel like if you watch
it
like a month or two or even a year late
it's
irrelevant um yeah i mean
i mean even even the release schedule to
the website he's played with the
timeline where it's like
you've moved into the office and then
you haven't and then you have again
yeah you're right then you have it and
then you've been in there for like two
months and then suddenly it's moving day
again and you're like what
but it yeah but it works it it he really
makes it work
yeah because it's not about necessarily
the timeline it's about the characters
yeah um so yeah
so those are the four things that are
happening on green light and then
peter's new bones
is probably next week so so keep on the
lookout for that because it's going to
go fast
guys there's only 206 points we can only
contribute one
so we're just gonna throw it up there
someday next week and
not say anything now people who have
greenlit shows in the past
uh they get a cool little icon next to
their name when they're doing like for
example when they're in the live stream
and things like that
is there a cool little bone icon for the
206 people
that's that's we're gonna do all 206
bones
and each person is going to get an
individual bone icon i know
jeez at this rate we're going to need a
flare wallet where people can like
choose what flare they actually want to
have next to their name or else
people says like they'll say one word
and then the username and the icons will
take up the entire chat
yeah we we we're gonna we're gonna limit
it to three i think
so people have to pick their favorite
three things it's pretty cool though i
like the idea of like you have this
badge of honor was like i've been here i
helped greenlight this show like
i was a producer on this show you know i
think that's pretty cool yeah
and on the lines of forum we're gonna
start
building out the account feature like a
lot a lot more robustly so we're talking
like phone
um all that's going to be on there it's
going to be great
publicly viewable um then we're going to
take it all and sell it to a big
corporation it's it's gonna be wild
yeah uh no but we're gonna we're gonna
allow people to um
host some of their own content on there
so that when they interact in forums
like
you can put up stuff and then you know
like exchange that knowledge back and
forth and i also think that'll be a
really cool way to like get
some more um videos from people that are
members of the site and then you know
maybe like once a month we can do like a
feature
thing for cool videos that people have
uploaded
yeah yeah dude i'm excited for like how
the site's gonna evolve this year
because
it's such a a great opportunity for
us outside of the youtube ecosystem
to let us still kind of live the life
that we've
learned to live with the youtube
ecosystem or like we can be so much
less concerned about algorithm and much
more concerned with just
making good content and that's a really
nice thing that the website brings
brings to the table yeah you know what
also though it's funny i
i've kind of been you know in the back
of my head i'm like oh man we got to get
these
these season one green light shows out
you know it's like it's taken months
it's been you know like last september
and
and
i'm and i'm starting to realize like
like part of it like when we first
started this whole thing
we're thinking a little bit of like
still that mini netflix model of like
all right we have these exclusive shows
around here
but you know since all the shows are a
little bit bigger we're accomplishing
building them out all by ourselves you
know there's it's not like
oh yes there's been new hires here and
we're growing at the pace we need to
grow at to make everything
but you know it's funny seeing our
situation versus
like still other streaming services and
the amount of content that's being put
out
and it's like wow it's like well these
are gonna be
the shows we're putting out are big
shows season one shows are
are sorry phase one i guess we're
calling it phase one shows
they're all big shows you know even this
dnd show we're looking we just started
you know post on it today and trying to
figure out such a massive undertaking
yeah it's like holy completely we
completely underestimated
how big of a show it was yeah and i i
don't think any of us could have known
otherwise like yeah and i mean even for
a d d show it's like wow like this is
this is a lot of stuff i mean like we
we're getting it figured out here and
it's not gonna like
bankrupt us by any means but it's still
like one of these like
holy crap this is like it's like yeah
we're talking about eight hours of
content and
putting as much effort into it as we do
with everything else so
some of the way to approach things i
mean this this is our whole like
business ethos that we've had at
corridor since we started which is
you know you look at like cuibi or any
of the other like streaming platforms
you know the way they do it is like they
get a whole bunch of venture capital
money
and they go out and they shotgun as much
content at you as you can
and it's just a total like i hope this
lands because if it doesn't we all go
bankrupt
yeah it's like that's not a that's not a
good life to live like that's such a
like
corporate you know i'm going to use my
golden parachute and get out of this if
it doesn't work
like pretending you're bigger than you
are for the sake of like tricking people
yeah it's like if you actually enjoy
what you're doing and you actually love
your job
the whole idea is not to just shotgun as
much content at people as you can
yeah the idea is to enabling
yeah like you know our whole approach is
to like we want to connect
with the people that want to like that
enjoy the stuff that we make
and so and we want to continue making
the stuff that we enjoy making as well
and like ideally those two things go
together i enjoy
making things with you know cool gun
fights and explosions and there's people
out there who enjoy cool gun fights and
explosions and ideally we meet each
other
on the internet and like the whole
business model has just been the process
of
building that up in a sustainable way
like you know
back when we started on youtube like the
whole thing i was like oh we could go
make a movie
easy look at all these things they do
wrong movies and muscle flashes are
always bad and it's like then once you
get into making a movie you're like
oh this is really complicated and really
hard and it's really not about you it's
a whole team of people and
everybody has to bring their egg yeah
once you get in the post on a big
project like that you're like i know
exactly
why the muzzle flashes look bad in most
movies
because i'm struggling to make ours look
good here it's just like
i have so many other things to worry
about than the muzzle flashes and like
it gets passed off to like some random
person
and they're just like here you go and
it's like these kind of look mediocre
like out of time
and you're like oh okay i guess we'll
live with them but
yeah you know it's like so there's a
whole learning process and a whole team
that needs to be built you know around
that kind of stuff really at the end of
the day good movies happen because
there's good teams behind him and you
don't just
manifest a good team instantly from
nothing you
you spend your time building it you know
if you look at corridor right now you
know we've been building
a good team by every year bringing on
two to three new people
and little by little and then it's not
an instant all right turn around and
make stuff let's say let's
get to know each other let's get to
understand the content you're making
let's listen to the audience's feedback
and use that to round yourself out as a
filmmaker because
nobody just comes out of the gate
perfect like it just doesn't work that
way
you need to and then and the endeavor
isn't to
like hey we need to you need to come on
so we could do this thing so we could do
that and then that that
it's like no that the idea is to try to
come up with a situation where we can
can
we we can make like a a life's work of
of artistic content yeah contribute that
to like the medium that is
audio visual art yeah it's like it's
yeah
it's not something you want to just do
in like a year or
a month or you know it takes time
and and that's part of it that's part of
the deal
so i guess that's why we only i mean
we've got crew cuts season two and
dubstep guns
is the only sort of real project based
stuff or even dubstep guns too
is is the only like dedicated
filming piece because crew cuts is you
know an ongoing
daily thing for daniel so i guess that's
that's why we've got
more enhancements like the forums and
the corridor live
versus like dedicated shows is you know
the fact that you guys had you know
tactical reloads
son of a dungeon functional filmmaking
crew cuts season one
and local zero that was that was an
ambitious start
to green light i mean it's like you said
in in the very before we'd even gone
live it was like if all of these get
green lit
we are screwed yeah and they all did
except for tactical yeah uh
yeah that's i mean those are going to be
rolling out like over the course of the
year here
and then obviously like you know in a
few more months we'll probably follow up
and we'll do a phase three of green
light and that'll have
some more narrative stuff in it and
that'll be like kind of
for 2022 you know um
we want to make sure we deliver on what
we promised people would deliver on like
you know we never did a kickstarter in
our entire career here at corridor we've
never done an indiegogo
and like part of that is just because
it's so easy just to not deliver on it
you know and that's not a situation that
i want to be and i want
i want to deliver on the things that we
say we're going to deliver on
but it's also you know i want to do cool
stuff at the same time
and bring those two together takes time
like you know sam's obviously
you know kind of the leading creative
force behind local zero but like
behind that is a whole realm of you know
animation
motion capture capture real time
rendering uh virtual filmmaking like all
these really cool things that like
i'm totally into and like sam's totally
into
and like we want to learn and experiment
and like
make sure we can make cool stuff with
that and it's not just like a
a quick like running out the door and
move on to the next thing yeah i mean
when we put it up on the green light
page
if i would have made it after it was
green lit i mean it would be out by now
but it'd be really shitty
[Laughter]
you can you can literally track the
quality of how good it
is gonna be by every corridor crew video
that has anything to do with unreal
engine
and yeah but we do have like you know we
do
have like a semi script for the thing
already which i really like where it's
going it's got some really cool scenes
and it's
you know i think the other aspect that's
important to keep in mind is like
we're not hunting for the most popular
shows we're hunting for
doing stuff that's unique to our voice
that can't be enabled
anywhere else like you know youtube you
have to make stuff
for a bigger audience that's not to say
you know you can't make cool things that
appeal to a bigger audience but like
you're still kind of playing the
algorithm game um
but like yeah if you know you want to
have success on youtube you have to play
the algorithm game that's
how it works yeah and then if you're
going to make something like netflix
you're still playing the algorithm game
it's a different algorithm but like
you're still very much like the
executive producer saying like all right
i need some
romance here and i need you to do
cliffhangers here
and the subject matter needs like we
need something that's really broad
in mass audience so i can market it into
this you know portfolio here and it's
like
you're still missing out on like the
niche art
like the cool things like like i don't
like let me put it this way
how many mad max fury roads do we get
every year like zero
right we get zero mad max fury roads
every year
and like that's one of the coolest films
i've seen in the past like two decades
uh but they don't come out that often
because honestly that
kind of movie doesn't fit into a
business portfolio you know it's just a
you make it and you hope it turns out
good and you hope people like it but
that's not really what people do when
they have millions of dollars at stake
you know if they have millions of
dollars to take they're going to go with
the tried and true method where it's a
known commodity
but we get to do something like local
xero which has a pretty unique plot and
a really unique idea that
it's cool and i think a lot of people
are really going to like it because it
speaks to a lot of people's
modern experiences with both gaming and
like virtual lifestyles and living
online so to speak
in that culture that's around that but
you won't ever get netflix touching
something like that and if they do
it might be cool for a couple episodes
then it's just gonna become the same
generic
like gotta hit the numbers gotta play
you know you know gotta fall into the
sitcom
you know aspect of the whole thing but
yeah you know what i'm also not saying
there's no
good shows on netflix there's obviously
a lot of great trails in netflix but
it's just
what everybody has been enabling us to
do with the website is they're letting
us
forge this new type of entertainment and
it's
you know we're starting it's a little
slow and we're starting small because
we're
a tinier company by you know by
everybody else's standards but
it's just really exciting and the fact
that we're hitting this second iteration
of the website
it's going to be exciting a to see how
people respond to functional filmmaking
be to continue growing the website and
trying to
gather enough of a subscriber base to
let us really pursue
these narrative pieces with some budget
and
you know i guess he will just be like
what happens this fall or next
you know next winter when we've kind of
moved through this phase and entering
phase three
you know we've got we'll have uh some
experience under our belts it's like
then what happens
like that'll be really cool yeah it's
it's i mean it also
like as we're seeing with like the
forums feature
like why are we doing that we're doing
that because it it's it's
it gives you a tool that didn't really
there wasn't really an outlet for it
that we had sort of direct access to
in a way that like i guess
calls upon like sam said that the
knowledge base
that that will be built up there and
the ability to take that and then
bring it bring it to be um
we didn't have like a place for that
before we're like hey that's a good idea
you know somebody should do that but we
didn't
now we have a place to do it um so it's
it's beyond just
it's beyond just even like the
narratives and and the the other
like it's it's like i see it as there's
so many different
now avenues that we can take with it um
that we still maintain that nimbleness
that we've always had to have with
youtube but
um you know now it's just uh
i guess there's a lot there's
you can take it into you can take it
into the 20 like in this 21st century
honestly it's like
that's that's where that's what i'm
feeling with it
one of the things that i think i love
the most is that like green light
didn't exist for the first maybe like
six months six plus months that we were
building the website like originally
it was just let's build a website let's
bring in more revenue
that can fund projects and then
you know i think it was either nico or
sam came along and said actually we kind
of want
something that's a little bit more and
then i can't even remember how
green light came into conception but it
did and then as soon as it did it was
it just made so much sense and you know
whilst
the offering isn't ridiculous we don't
have 10 20 30 shows for people to pick
it's
you know something that is evolving and
you know with each iteration of green
light is is going to grow and change as
we figure out
what did work what didn't work um you
know
something right like in a couple more
years
there's going to be a huge library on
there and it's going to be really
i think really cool to see it to look
back on it i'm just waiting for somebody
else to copy our green light feature
i know i called my buddy who's a patent
lawyer about that
and it's yeah
i don't know i don't know if it's
patentable but dude just give it like
give it
give it like once our site gets a little
more notoriety like
just give it a minute and then like
netflix is gonna come on be like vote
for which show we make next and then
it's like oh
there it is with netflix we've we've got
three billion dollars where do you think
we should put it it's like
damn they did it way better than we did
i mean hey those guys though they
started by
sending out dvds in the mail
yeah they're the first ones to be like
what if we streamed these couple crappy
movies that we didn't have to worry
about rights
you know like distribution rights for
and then i was like we love it and it's
like oh
i remember in in it was it must have
been about 2004
my buddy joe had his mom had a netflix
subscription
and it was you know 299 or whatever a
month
and they'd send you two or three dvds
and then you had to send them back
and then and then you get and then your
subscription continued can you imagine
trying to manage that logistically like
yeah screw that it's such a it's such a
different model than it is now
i mean i guess amazon started as a book
company right you know so
yeah think about it speaking of netflix
at least you didn't have to return the
books
yeah that's true yeah is anybody
watching the new f1
uh season on netflix
no no man it's like the best show nobody
watches it
f1 like racing yeah f1 racing all right
so
imagine you're an average person an
average american
who doesn't give a crap about f1 racing
okay perfect
all right you got a great audience all
right so that's describing probably
everybody here
um so now imagine i came along i said
what if since you don't give a crap
about f1 racing what if i
just took every single race filmed it
with a bunch of phantom cameras and
helicopters and drones may look real
pretty i had gopros in the cockpit i had
voice recordings for everybody
and what if i edited every race down to
only the important parts
so the crashes like the malfunctions
like the team drama
and then what if i also gave you a
little bit of context before each race
as to why it's important and what's at
stake with each character
both in terms of their careers and their
rivalries and then you got to watch it
all play out on the track in real time
and what if i took those multiple hours
of you know
sports bs and made it 30 minutes long
sports
bs you would probably like that sounds
like a lot of fun like what if i write
like
what if i just say like hey i know i'm
so i'm sorry
i love watching racing but it's like i
can't watch
much of it like a lot of like throughout
3000
yes no thank you like here's just 30
minutes
by some really good editors with some
great phantom angles of cars just
shattering into a million pieces at like
5 000 frames per second and you're like
yeah
that sounds amazing i mean i do know
some people that have watched
the netflix series and now watch f1 and
are
really into it because of the netflix
series where they're like i didn't
realize
f1 was that interesting it was like
cricket
yeah well it's like you know when you
like turn on the tv just like to the
layman like it's hard to kind of see
what's going on in a race
and it doesn't seem all that crazy it
seems like everybody just drives the
optimized route and that's it
but once you start watching the series
you start realizing like i mean
engineering is such a huge part of f1
racing
i'd say even more so than like you know
uh like indy car racing or whatever you
know the
daytona and stuff is nascar racing like
i mean obviously engineering's a big
part of that too but
in f1 racing it's like it's a huge part
of it it's way more like
you know here's your constraints go
crazy and do whatever you want within
those constraints and so all these
people are coming out with crazy
different like
you know things on their cars and like
technological advancements and
you know they're protesting to like the
like the fia or whatever to like be like
they can't do that with their car like
for example and like in the first
episode mercedes is a thing where if you
pull your
uh steering wheel in and out it turns
the front tires in and out like you know
like it pizza wedges them you know like
like when you're skiing
and so they could do that to get like
extra traction when they're going around
a circle like a corner and they'd you
know
once on a straight away they pulled the
thing out and the tires go straight and
they can go faster
and all the other teams like what you
can't do that they're like oh we can
totally do it
it's like little things like that and
you get like the dynamics of it all and
like
drivers are constantly being poached
from team to team and like contracts are
being negotiated so you get like drivers
who like
they're leaving the team at the end of
the year so they're just like screw you
i'm gonna do whatever i want
and you get like rivalries in the track
where people within the same scene
is like crashing into each other i feel
like i'm this is like speed racer you're
describing it it is speed racer where
they're like
see sam you can't make fun of all sports
all the time
i know that's so funny yeah they're like
you can't do that you can't do an oil
slick
that comes at the back of your car it's
like oh yeah
so mercedes is the best team and they
have like a number one driver and they
have their second driver
who hates that he's like being called
the number two driver right he's like
i'm just as good as this other dude but
they always put him in first place and
i'm
stuck competing and like so they're
doing a race and you have to qualify
before you do a race where you just do
time trials and that your timing
dictates where you are in the grid
and so of course the number one driver
gets you know the best time
and this guy is getting the number two
time but he's like you know what when
you're starting a race on this track
because it's a big straightaway
you want to be in third place because
you want the car in front of you
punching a hole in the air
and that gives you the boost around the
first corner and then you can take the
lead
and so as he's doing his qualifying time
and like all right you got the second
best time
he's like cool i'm like cool uh feel
free to you know step off the gas he's
like
cool whatever and then he continues like
driving fast on the straightaway
while the red bull car behind him is
starting their lap time so he ends up
giving him a full like
draft boost for that part like why are
you doing that he's like no reason
and the whole reason is because he
wanted to give that guy a little bump in
time so that that guy
would get the second best time and then
he'd have the third best time
but he like didn't listen to his coaches
he didn't listen anyways like i'm just
going to do this
because i'm tired of being the number
two driver i'm going to take first place
in this one
it's like you don't get that from just
watching on tv
but they give you that in this in this
show so yeah i highly recommend it
also anybody seeing see congress
godzilla
i've watched most of it i i've i
got two thirds of the way through and
then i just watched the sweet fight at
the end dude how about that boat fight
it was great yeah pretty good i watched
it with gideon and he was like dragons
oh yeah and like i was like thank god
you're not scared of this now i can like
now i can watch these movies in the
morning
6 a.m boom godzilla we're doing it
but no it's great there's some great
spoilers that we could talk about
it's it's not even a spoiler it's like
wrestling it's like you're saying that's
right
godzilla versus congress if i'm gonna
tell you dude the undertaker shows up
and starts fighting and you're like dude
come on
spoiler alert sorry if you haven't seen
the movie yet you give a crap about
spoilers it's freaking mechagodzilla in
there i'm like
yeah hell yeah robo dinosaurs and [ __ ]
yeah i'm like this is great like the
movie's dumb though the movie's dumb as
hell
but it's so it's so dumb
this movie is like it's like this movie
feels like it was written by a
six-year-old and that's a good thing
and a bad thing yep and i will say the
cg
in that movie is so well done and they
do some really cool stuff with it
although my only part though is that
like there's a sub because the
conspiracy theory subplot
and i'm like dude this is like this is
like almost funnier after the q anon
stuff
where i'm like i'm like it's like this
girl
read someone's twitter and has like
decided to break into government
agencies based off what she read on the
internet
like that's a that's a huge plotline
she's a hero
and it's like it's funnier and i feel
like they could have maybe leaned into
that a bit but
wow yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's amazing um all right real quick
before we end here scott
was that what was the best thing about
getting the site to this point and what
was the
hardest thing about getting it to this
point
uh well the best thing
generally is the reactions in the
comments section whenever something
changes
like there's a couple of people in
particular that always comment
and it's like it's that thing where it's
like i kind of secretly know them
because they just they always
say really nice things you're like the
bartender you're like
yeah it's the usual huh yeah but it's
like no it's super
like you know sometimes software
developers don't get much recognition
for the work that they do so
having kind of that really close
connection with like people complain
about stuff
and then in fact most the time when
people open up support tickets they're
like hey scott i've got this problem
you know so people people know that i'm
answering those tickets
before i've even replied um the worst
part
this is going to sound stupid but video
video is just
like it's so easy there's
so many different options and variables
and
configurations for video doesn't matter
how long you've done it for
it's it's an industry and a technology
that is
always changing so you know
yeah we haven't had too many issues but
it's it's a lot more
pain than you know than
some people may appreciate when you know
they click a video and it plays and it's
like well that
took a lot to get there in the first
place
anything from a dying server to you know
just
format issues so who your mom picking up
the phone in the middle of your download
dude that's a macros joke that's an old
mac os joke
that goes for breakfast all right all
right guys
well is it time for our musical outro
i think so all right here i got a little
song i've been working on
a little cover a little yeah that's
right a hand pan cover from another
handpan song here we go
really all right let's hear it i'm sorry
we're not getting any banjo or guitar
for this outro
is this an eco original it is not
actually i did not write
my phone i might solo over the top of it
just cool
all right this was written by kate stone
[Music]
that's it that's all i got
it's actually kind of hard playing with
the microphone here because i get some
songs on that thing now
yeah man you're learning songs
sweet all right next time on the
corridor cast
we do an entire hour of just improvised
hand pan
and uh people are intelligent
people dubstep
hand panned all right and and the
reading of
chinese proverbs until next time
all right all right peace guys
[Music]
check out quarterdigital.com yeah if you
didn't get that already
from from the hour
thanks guys.com all right cheers guys
bye
see ya